you have so many characters that you
play I never know when I'm talking to
you or one of your characters one of
your favorites you've said recently is
this Daath character that you've done on
Portlandia yeah I think we have a
picture yeah does the character have a
name that that's Vince
that's Vince okay yeah and he's just
sort of like he's very normal but he
just looks that way so this season we go
to Bed Bath & Beyond and goose go
shopping you know when you go there and
you just things just keep adding up and
you try to get the cool thing but it's
still just Bed Bath & Beyond now you've
said of all the characters you do you
set an interview that the goth character
or Vince is kind of the one that's
closest to you that rely most like me
yeah why is that just because I still
try to get things that are sort of like
black you know what I mean like I'll get
and like trying to be cool but at the
same time you know I'm basically a
normal person I'm saying so it's it's
it's I keep trying to do cool things but
end up getting what everyone else gets
right except these glasses I think
glasses are I don't think I've seen
these before these are amazing yeah
these are made by Mark Mothersbaugh you
know the singer from Devo yeah yeah
[Applause]
those glasses real close look two three
right there those are sick keep getting
in closer closer closer this is like a
QVC moment
Portlandia this exciting our own Andy
Richter well believe us is-is-is on an
upcoming episode yeah Andy was a guess
that's true this really happened there
was an actor on our show who said I just
went to this big company and I had that
I was hired to get fired over and over
again by different employees being
trained to fire people oh and this
person so it was to train people how to
fire someone but they needed someone to
fire yes that's cool so over and over
again and right there we were like oh
there's our next sketch right
so Andy played that person yes yeah yeah
you just popped to mind yeah
you